vermehren oder besser mond premiere zum
ersten mal überhaupt wird eine mondsonde
auf der rückseite des bundeslandes wird
eine chinesische sonne sein was wird sie
dort vorfinden
es gibt verschwörungstheorien nach denen
dort stellte bilder oder es sehen gäbe
und natürlich bitter verjüngt durch
alien technologie wohnen aber mindestens
so verrückt ist das hammer eine halbe
million klicks roman interview
wenn es einer gesagt hätte dann sich mit
wissenschaft videos das erreiche ich
hätte es nicht für möglich keit extremes
darf und für den interessieren 500.000
menschen zurück und jetzt alle sich in
ihm wohnt konnte
nicht umsonst gibt es täglich spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst der familie also los gehts
war herzlich willkommen heute von des tc
xp das ist die größte comic on der welt
und die gibt es im juni auch bei uns in
deutschland wahnsinn und das hinter mir
ist das raumschiff von men in black 4
bald in den kinos und das raumschiff
gibt es sie ja zum ersten mal zu sehen
ist übertrieben aber trotzdem eine
weltpremiere in gewissem maße
der mann
er ist auch nicht totzukriegen auf der
rückseite des mondes lebenstedt den
wälder und seen also da kam nicht normal
entwarnen und das wird die sonne
wohl auf keinen fall mit mehr man wird
eine sonde nordland bisher haben es alle
welt vom nationen betreut
auf der rückseite des mondes zu landen
weil das mit deutlich erhöhtem aufwand
verbunden ist denn nicht nur dieser
länder wird zum mond geschickt werden
sondern auch ein mond satellit als
relaisstation um sie signale an die erde
zu wenden denn er wollte ja länderkampf
von der rückseite nicht direkt senden
weil der mond ja dazwischen ist das geht
nur über einen satelliten der von der
erde aus gesehen werden kann und vom
länder aus quasi über ämtern gesenkt
allerdings würde es zumindest keine
überraschungen
neben den die mond rückseite wurde
bereits seit 59 von der rutsche
nun die drei aufgenommen hier eine neue
aufnahme des
im kommissions- anbieters von der
rückseite aus dem jahr 2009 also schon
mal keine sind
gesehen
sonst wird es auch die sonde die alle
apollo nannte plätze blockiert hat
und land und skeptiker jetzt halt so
eine chinesische konnte ich zum ersten
mal auf der rückseite landeten schon
vier du hast sehr gut einem monat wird
sie nach dem starken slot im antiken
theater landen nach dem touchdown wird
ein roboterfahrzeug den länder verlassen
und die umgebung untersuchen neben
diversen messgeräten ist auch eine
panorama bar an bord zusätzlich ist auch
ein kleines gewächshaus mit auf dem mond
wird getestet wie pflanzen
bei der liga
gravitation des
es wachsen
kleine info am rande der durch das pink
floyd album dark side of the moon
inspiriert ist zu glauben dass die
rückseite des mondes
dunkel ist nein immer bei mir auf der
erde und essen haben der mond hat dunkel
ist es die rückseite hält und umgekehrt
jede seite des mondes ist also gleich
hell so dass das nicht für ein solches
experiment immer mehr als ausreichend
ist wir können also auf die ergebnisse
gespannt sein hier werden wir euch
darüber berichten wenn er dazu und zu
allen an dem kein wieder verpassen wollt
dann abonniert auf den englischen kanal
verwicklung
dennoch gibt es immer öfter
videopremieren dafür einfach hier
klicken und darunter geht es weiter mit
what you aliens nein ich freue mich auf
euch aus dem englischen kanal
hierzu
stay tuned